after months in lockdown restaurants are
back but they're coming out of
hibernation and into a strange new world
shaped by the corona virus pandemic
[Music]
I'm Tim Hayward I'm a restaurateur cook
and food writer
[Music]
I'm Daniel Guerin ham and the
journalists at the Financial Times and I
love eating out we want to see how the
restaurant business is adapting as we
came out of lockdown and what eating out
will look like in the future our first
stop is miles the Michelin star
restaurant in London the shortage how
could a fine-dining restaurant like this
survive Tim good to see you and you mate
the UK is unlocking restaurants are
starting to reopen it's a exciting time
it's a challenging time for restaurants
too isn't oh you're not kidding and no
more so than here it's the cutting edge
of the restaurant phenomenon in the UK
what we've seen over the last couple of
decades and yet it's right here on the
street that marks the edge of the city
and hipster central I'm looking over
there and it's empty there's nothing
moving in the city I don't know what's
happening in it it's the central figures
nobody's been in there in three months
these challenges ahead for all different
types of restaurant businesses but then
there's the dining experience as well
I'm desperate to get out there and eats
haven't been out to eat in a restaurant
first several months like most of the
people in the country and yet at the
same time feeling a bit cautious what
does this new experience gonna look like
are we going to be safe is it going to
be an enjoyable experience well I'm
going to be really interested to see
what you think as a hunter because when
they make those guidelines sit it's
going to be the difference between
whether you're desperate to go where
you're gonna go once and you're gonna go
sorry
I don't even like you together anymore
yeah a romantic candlelit dinner for two
served by a waiter or waitress wearing
protective clothing and a visor is that
going to be an enjoyable or romantic
experience who knows and here's your
wine and I'll give you a bed bar it's
sort of a hospital dining experience if
these guys can't crack it nobody can
should we go in there and see what
they're up to
Lyle's was co-founded by general manager
John and head chef James they also run
floor a bakery and coffee shop across
the city in Borough Market couple of
weeks was brutal and at that point not
having
any sort of support in place and just
not really knowing anything you're the
first Michelin guys I've had the
opportunity to ask what do you think is
gonna happen to me now after this well
the guy that got around a reassess
everybody as we come out of it it's the
kind of panicking that they won't be
able to sell their next their next guy
because it's essentially the same this
one from the previous year because
nobody will want to say anything
negative about with its Michelin star at
the place of the annual world's 50 best
restaurants rankings laurels attracts
international food tourists in normal
times for now it remains closed
you haven't be opens for the big
reopening weekends but I mean is that
the decision you're gonna take anytime
soon you think that there is a little
bit of well let's see what happens
because I certainly think that people
will give an outdoor seating more of a
shot than they will do being inside a
restaurant I remember when we opened in
every single person the restaurant
industry came in and just said oh you
get way more way more seats in here
we've put our cap on how many people we
thought we could do reasonably that was
48 so used to be 48 seats so how many
covers would you have and thinking about
32 so it's a reduction but it's not too
drastic
you know you don't want to make that
sound too positive because 10-15 percent
less turnover ten fifty percent less
covers is an enormous difference that
could be the difference between where
they were just breaking even for a long
time and actually generating a profit is
it gonna be worth reopening for you do
you think I'm not entirely convinced or
I just don't know yet how I feel about
people are gonna react to going out to a
restaurant the concern about eating in
or eating out and I think it's hugely
divisive at the moment you get half the
people going you know you I can't
believe you're open that is inhumane
what are you doing you're killing
everyone to the other half go you've got
to get out there and support these
people I'm hearing a lot from operators
finance people largely who are running
restaurant groups and chains and hubs of
vertical drinking place so they want
people to go back and I don't hear a lot
from chefs who are all about their
creative expression and their brand that
had outfits
hearing a deadly silence from waiters
waitresses with Sommeliers and well how
are they feeling right now this must be
really scary for them yeah petrifies the
pressure and responsibility I felt most
is people looking at me and James
Frances I me and James going I don't
know kitchens looking a little bit
different at the moment we clipped all
of our production from restaurant food
to our pastries viennois Zuri which is
what we do at a other restaurant floor
down in Borough Market it's it's useful
time to give people a bit of training
something different to justify paying to
get them some money and you won't ever
tempted to keep the kitchen open to do
delivery or DIY pets in the way that
some other restaurants are one of the
things that really makes the food here
stand out is balance and timing things
are taken through your product and
served in a very short space of time and
that does not work what do you think
it's gonna look like in this restaurant
when you are serving again indoors a bit
odd that tables are further apart it's
gonna feel a little sterile yes
potentially I mean but people John we've
been criticised that for a long time
anyway so I don't really mind exactly
the same here we are as it always was
100% support anyone this opened yeah to
not open when you've been told you can
open with the current financial
situation is a hard decision to make
to plan long-term is at the moment is
pointless exercise you just have to
react to what is happening to try and
keep things going so I was going to ask
for a nice clean prediction and it
actually is kind of heartening but there
isn't one for this this place it's going
to be good you're going to do the right
thing but you're not going to be rushed
into committing to something very
specific the only thing I will sit here
and say about anything that James and I
will do is it will be good what any of
those things are let's see it turns out
that shortage has been a ghost town ever
since the UK went into lockdown so John
and James pivoted to pizza converting
floor into an open hatch delivery and
takeaway it's kept them afloat and it
means they don't have to rush to reopen
liars
it seems that logical extension to brand
I really want to know what these guys
will do with the pizza we're using the
same suppliers the same grain the same
mills pistes 36-hour sourdough fermented
pizza dough so on a Sunday in our first
week but we didn't really know what
we're doing by seven o'clock we had sold
out so this is floor and it doesn't look
like it's opening up again as a
restaurant space anytime soon no I think
with the restrictions at the moment
there's not really the opportunities
here it's not really viable I think
downstairs in my bar you can't have
anyone and even in a meter you have 12
people with floor closed for indoor
dining floors landlord borough market
agreed to provide some outside dining
space for the new pizza operation a
tenant or landlord can bury the head at
the moment or you can have a discussion
about how you can make things work
businesses going under is not gonna pay
the rent in three months or six months
time the people who aren't prepared
to explore and look at other avenues of
Revenue and layering a business other
businesses that potentially again a
struggle has always been that question
like he gets all the soot guilty guilty
pleasure of what you're eating and I've
always said I don't really know I didn't
don't think I have one then they find
out a lot of pieces I've got your guilty
pleasures also eats up is amazing cheese
and a cured pork and chili product no
it's not what do you think the whole set
up at the diner I would come here and
buy this this is why I've been yearning
to do this doesn't frighten me and it
feels quite safe and I think what
they've done is by clinically they've
used the resources they have
but you also see what it's like on the
other side how they're having a shift to
keep their their brands protected that
people protected their suppliers paid
their bills papers land Google's
involved in the process god knows what I
left you like for a small operator so
I'm really glad we got to see how tough
even for the big boys I do you know the
proper name places it is hard as hell to
the ego as well think you think so it's
one about a Michelin star chef who's
used to cooking the most refined food
being forced by Pavan 19-2 having to
make it I think I'm saying cuz they
really rather enjoy it we don't admit
him I think they love something in our
food basic well it certainly shows
doesn't so you wouldn't
besides good as it looks it smells nice
much better